My husband doesn't cook, but I've been missing Germany so much lately
that tonight he asked me
whether I could show him one of my favourite German dishes to cook
so he could cook it for me.
So tonight we made some red braised cabbage,
also known as horde cod and Yugoslav.
We started by dicing some onions,
shredding some cabbage, combining that with water,
apple cider vinegar, sugar,
salt and red currant jelly.
I let that go for about an hour and a half
while we got started on our mushroom sauce.
I sliced up some mushrooms
and then lucky went ahead and started sauteing some shallots
and some butter. Once our shallots were soft,
he added in all of our sliced mushrooms.
Once those were cooked down,
we added in some beef stock,
some heavy cream and thickened our sauce with a cornstarch slurry.
We let that simmer away and started pounding out pork loins.
I like making my schnitzel with either pork or veal,
but today it was pork. Once all of our cutlets were pounded out,
we set up our breading station with some eggs,
bread crumbs and some flour that we seasoned.
And then it was time to bread our pork
dipped in the flour, first the eggs and then the bread crumbs,
and then fried it until golden brown
before sprinkling it with some salt while it was still warm,
and then we could plate. We put down the cabbage,
the schnitzel, our mushroom, Sauce.
This was so nostalgic to me.
And obviously lucky did clean up after.